[Music]
how many people you can get in one of
these it's like you're outside of a
sporting event or something is about to
take place because you have people
arriving and coming and going I've never
seen anything like this I've seen guys
at Grand Central Station
taking a bath in so that's fine I got no
problem with that
we're here in the Delhi Metro we've got
trains flying past us during our
interview welcome to India
there you go
we're spending the whole day with an
energy expert dr. Arnav oh gosh and we
are using the city itself to illustrate
an interview this is an interview we
could have done it in an office sat down
talked for an hour and gotten it done
instead we're running all around the
city and really trying to bring
everything that we're talking about to
life so this is going to pop out 500
lights right you know cooling systems
fans all around the station it seems to
be a very difficult sell in my country
we started off showing him solar system
at a subway station and then we took a
ride all the way through town we talked
about India's energy challenges we know
we are going to be the largest country
in the world in terms of population and
the second of third largest economy in
the world so we've got to have an energy
system that provides to the people and
for the economy
we got here in the old part of town and
they've looked around and he was a
little taken aback by the electricity
wires or tangled up honest to god what
is that
those are lexically wires this
infrastructure has not been upgraded for
a very very long time
isn't that like Dave are you done with
the wiring
well should we have a guy come up look
at that'll be all right I think Dave
isn't shocked I asked him are you over
with and he said yes and a good way you
know everybody says New York has an
energy not like this but I notice here
whatever the electrification situation
is it has not impeded this hyperactive
level of Commerce here is a country the
world's biggest democracy going to be
the world's largest population is making
this democratic choice that we are going
to have a cleaner energy system that's
the best message Dave can take back
[Music]
you
[Music]